hey what are you guys doing out here  it's halloween we've been  trick-or-treating are you alone there's  a creepy man in a white mask  where  and he keeps like trying to play hide  and seek with us where did you see him  run go now  come on  [Applause]  [Music]  we killed michael  my grandmother set the fire  no one told you  told me what  michael myers is alive  man couldn't have survived that fire  40 years ago the boogeyman came for us  we are the survivors of michael myers  what do we do we fight  mom our family we'll kill him we're  gonna hunt him down and we're gonna put  an end to this  he is not gonna stop killing until we  stop him  if you track michael's victims that's a  straight line  to michael's childhood home  someone's in our house  he's coming for me  but i'm coming for him  you want to kill someone take me michael  [Applause]  i want to take his mask off and see the  life of leave his eyes  [Music]  you